hi okay in today's new york times
megan the stallion penned this powerful
op-ed
called why i speak up for black women
and she is making headlines for all the
right reasons and that comes after
another
headline-worthy project offering support
to women of color
who are pursuing their degrees that's
right she teamed up with amazon music to
start the
don't stop scholarship fund for women of
color working hard on any degree
anywhere in the world she is taking
applicants online
so in addition to her exploding music
career and advocacy
megan is finishing her own degree in
healthcare administration
at texas southern university
classy bougie busy
i love it megan i i mean carla are you a
megan fan
i am a megan fan i'm even a bigger megan
fan
because of this so often people leave
school because they don't have the money
and to have somebody behind you
it makes you want to say yes yes yes
i completely agree the way she is using
her platform is just
extraordinary um speaking of
extraordinary women
you may have seen rihanna's new savage
ex fenty show
on amazon and as usual everyone's
invited to a riri party
the fashion show was about inclusivity
diversity
races ethnicities different ages and
sizes on the runway and her online
campaign
and she's changing fashion norms so one
of her models went
totally viral and he's actually here
with us today
in the studio okay for his first
exclusive interview please welcome
stephen green
stephen you are all the rage everybody
loves you you've had such an incredible
response
how does it feel to be representing men
and have everyone so supportive and
saying
thank you for representing honestly that
moment what i thought was just for me
to you know get the opportunity to work
with rihanna and the savage fancy team
uh became so much bigger um to see the
impact that has had on men to really
just
take the initiative to go for your
dreams and to to go without boundaries
was amazing
i mean what does it feel like when you
get called by a riri
savage ex fenty team like
it's a dream it's definitely a dream i
thought it was a joke at first when
their production team reached out via
instagram and i had to double check with
my agent just to make sure like hey have
they seen the images of me
are they sure what i look like and they
definitely affirm me in their moments is
to say hey they they want you
and this is it this is a moment and it's
a god dream for sure
what do you think gave you the
confidence to put yourself out there in
the first place may i ask
honestly i think it's just really being
in tune with myself um
just knowing the gifts that god had have
given me um
to to to grow with it and you know to to
to
exceed my own expectations to really
just push the boundaries to know that i
have a loving support system
around me that really there's nothing
that i have to fear
well i think that is such a positive
message and
people especially men are really
embracing this and thanking you
for representing so beautifully with
your outside and your inside and your
perspective
and all of it so thank you stephen for
joining us here today
you are rocking that fenty thank you
so much thank you thank you you look so
handsome
thank you thank you you are beautiful oh
thank you
i got hair and makeup done you should
see me on the weekend you know
i didn't but you know i guess i'll make
it work
you obviously are making it work and
thank you for making it work here on our
[Music]
show
you